so you watched your uh
the first video we did together yep what
were your thoughts on that
i could talk a long time
but that's because at least in myself i
saw honesty
i saw things both good and bad
and things that made me see myself
as others may see me because
as individuals we don't know how we look
to others
um practicing in front of a mirror or
something does not
give you that full effect that seeing
yourself boom recorded and
now on bear with posterity there's
things that are a little
embarrassing and things that are
horrifying some that are
acceptable as is everyone's story
i'm not unique in that aspect because we
all have our own
core experiences some are more extreme
than others
yeah and it allowed me to see
just how
deep down that rabbit hole i went in
terms of my
choices in fun times
but it is what it is i hate that phrase
but it's reality it's my life
i have to accept it works and all
all i can do is now find my best points
enhance those pursue the things that
even disturbed me
and makes me a better person overall
it's not a bad thing that i recorded
myself it's not a bad thing that
i let you i allowed myself to be
recorded and posted and all that
i'm all right with that it's me
what also shocked me more than just
seeing myself
in the comment section as you well know
there's a lot of
idiots out there but then there's a lot
of good ones and dare i
say of the batch that i sampled
a little couple here and then scroll
down a lot and just catch a couple more
um more supportive
than i thought more
realizing hey we're all individuals and
you like let him be
do him and i liked that because that's
something that
is missing from those that fear
exposing themselves to others not like a
flasher
but more like just what's inside
here and if more people are able to do
that
and be unafraid
it's interesting to see how much of an
audience there is of
people to acknowledge it
and not chastise or demean or insult
i was happy about that sure there were
plenty of uh
people's pre-sufficient
supposed same of making comments or
suggestions or
beliefs about me that were either
ranging from could be something
all the way to oh wow that person is so
far off the mark
and and yeah
it doesn't matter what makes you think
of me no i'm still living
i'm still going to
live my life but i can do it
better and that's what that video taught
me
that's great thanks yeah i think i think
the audience at least on my channel
really appreciates honesty
that is what i was able to that's the
key to a lot of what you see on my
channel yeah
when the interviewee is very open and
honest and makes it makes them so
vulnerable
yeah that goes over really well even if
you're even if you're a bad
you know bad person yeah and it goes
over really well whereas when you come
in and you're protecting yourself and
you're
you're hiding this and you're hiding
that that doesn't go over well
that that shiny stuff yeah
it shows uh a distant genuineness
and just does not
allow that person to
put what they want to put out there
but yeah there's a lot of fear in people
and
yeah having the opportunity to do this
was like yeah um cliff diving from
someone that might be even afraid of
water
that's what it was like that's great
here i come cabo wherever the daniel
cliffs are that has a nice little
yeah but i'm
i'm happy for me that i'm able to
still be alive after the things i've
done but
also to be
accepting of myself there's so many
people that live in their
bubbles of comfort
but always regret not taking that one
step
outside of it
and hey i'm happy that i you know jumped
both feet out years ago
i think it's a big problem there's a lot
of people oh there's a problem okay a
problem with you know but some people
like that
um yeah because then they have regrets
and if they have the regrets then they
have the
anger and hate that comes out of it
i mean that's why they say most raging
homophobes are the
secret gay guys i mean i've never dealt
with um anything with a pastor or
anything like that but i would think 100
of them are i mean yeah i'm hey and i
can see that now
more so because i can realize like you
see a
a trans woman yeah and you you express
hatred towards her you you leave a mean
comment on my channel it's either
because you're turned on by it
and that you're not comfortable with
that yeah
or you have this same tendency and you
don't like that
yeah you're just but you're backing
somebody like i just think they're
interesting i hope they're happy
yeah and that's the reason why it felt
even more comfortable when i saw it
after the fact
is that there's these comments like this
ain't my thing at all
but you know he's not murdering anybody
and i haven't and i won't as far as i
know
but um and
i'm too incompetent with anything one
with weapons or
no i can't imagine um no but i found
your personality you'd be so
interesting and warm and easy
you're so easy to talk to and listen to
thank you and it's because of your
intelligence and it's also because of
your
ability to be vulnerable and honest and
and it just it just became a very
interesting talk
you know yes you're talking about stuff
that well i'm talking with that um
monologue is not a dialogue
for sure but you know it's certainly
you know controversial subject matter
but but but
your speaking style is great your
honesty is great your vulnerability made
it really
so easy to listen to thank you again
um and it helped me just yeah like i
said um
realize that what i'm doing ain't so
damn bad like
um like i said everyone's got their own
little skeletons in their closet
whatever it is
and once you accept yours
then there's no more skeletons you know
you can be free
of any constraint
and more people need to be like that
i'm surprised that that
um moment of clarity didn't happen until
really i saw
my video where i'm able to like see wow
the ugly but then they're good and
then the comments just was even more
supportive of the fact that i did do it
not necessarily of
what i do or what's done to me
but point is that um yeah
it's me
yeah i think i think you're charming and
interesting and
your your personality every time i see
you often now because you you live right
down
yeah street two blocks yeah everyone
even says behind your back
how delightful you are to hang out with
and that
that that that
i'm if i if it's a good camera lens
which it looks like it did in the videos
that i saw but
i mean i'm probably turning 50 shades of
red because i'm just like embarrassing
uh
blushing that's the word you know just
doing the nice thing so
as a good friend of mine back in detroit
a co-worker turned a very good friend of
mine
uh she she
was like whenever she would make a
comment or something and i caught it
like
you look at that and she's like oh
you're turning red you're blushing and
she would laugh at me about that and it
made me laugh and
yeah so that's how i feel like i am
right now i'm not you know
do you ever use what emotion do you deal
with most is it depression or anxiety or
anger or anything like that
you don't seem to have any of them i
have all of those in spades
you do uh-huh i
don't project that unless
that person brought it to me
and when that happens hell hath no fury
like me
angered by your dumbass
[Laughter]
so so are you one of these people that
just kind of puts on a
life of the party face all the time and
even though you might be very sad
behind the tears of a clown yeah i have
that a lot of people do that
um
i resemble my father a lot and he passed
away last december
um and when i think about
but my father's uh my co-workers or
other adults that were in the room like
what they would say about my father
like one time i called him at his job
and
like oh you're looking for the funny
little fat pillow so funny little fat
solo
was one of the nicknames for my father
that me and the family had um
because yeah he was the person that just
was silly but he was also
sincere helpful like trying to do the
right thing for others
alzheimer's and dementia
of god awful and after my father's
kidney transplant
it triggered that it was a slow decline
toward the end of the
um dialysis before the transplant but
then after transplant
he was gone he was around living
for 10 years after that but
he wasn't himself it was like a shell of
a person
and
as that you seen the last
life that he was familiar with like
he would constantly when i was his
primary caregiver because mom was still
working
and so i was with him and keep in mind
this is just after i got
discharged of the hospital after three
months where i had my severe mental
uh trauma that caused
me to have those same type of symptoms
that my father was having
and here i am healing myself but tending
to him as he's declining
and then he has seen that decline
and that he may not refer to the
name for him which is
of course for richard and that's what my
uncle would call him so
he would respond to dicky but not
necessarily richard her father
it was like some days he
didn't know who i was or who my mom was
but you know he would respond uh very
cheerfully
and that's where i'm trying to go here
because this is a
something i've not said before and it
hurts
it's just as my father was regressing
he was like thinking he was back in high
school
we had to get a double lock
a double um way you know the um you have
the key to
open the door to get out of the house we
had to
put that on the front door because he
loved to go out and wander and
look for people in the
um
apartment complex duplex complex
apartment building
looking for people to help them with
their groceries
his first job was a bad boy at a you
know market
and so he'd go on looking for people
that had bags or something so he could
help them because that's what he knew
what his job was
but that was you know 50 years prior
seeing that regression seeing
that was painful
and after two two and a half years of
being that
caregiver for them and finding some
resources
through charitable agencies and
non-profits and other things
to at least help alleviate the burden
from
myself and for my mother when she you
know was
after work or whatever and i found some
wonderful things that they used
years after i moved out but i had to for
my own sanity
and
if that's hereditary you know i mean i'm
not a diabetic like my father was
not that would but
i know i
don't want to wind up like that and if
there's anything i can do in my power to
prevent that from happening
i should probably pursue that and do
that
i don't have the
stable life of a loving wife
and children that
looked out for you i mean how one of
them gave him his kidney my brother
he was a perfect match
but i don't
i don't want to be
alone because i can see myself if i
lived that
similar life to my father in terms of
his
physical health i will not have someone
be willing to play private duty nurse
for a decade like my mom did
i'll be a vegetable in a nursing home
like i was in 2010 the only patient
there under 70 years old
and it
that will be my life if
i continue to waste away in terms of
a purpose and that's what you were
talking about in the touchdown you know
the last video
i still haven't found what i'm looking
for in terms of
a goal to life
and
i sure hope that hits me someday soon do
you feel like you've lived the life that
you wanted to
i have lived the best life based
on the cards that i've been dealt but i
stacked that deck
in a bad way i am aware of the
impediments to my
ideal self but i created it
you know rather than you know stuck in
the deck with you know wild cards i is
all you know like
twos or seven two if you're gonna play
poker
so i just
it's
it's very empowering
because i can see it it's just that
right motivation
and i must clean house
uh physically mentally every
capacity take a good deep look
at those i'm closest to
and make sure that it
is a circle of people that i see
there for the long haul
because i know there are some that are
not
some that are
a friend of mine in new york city not
the one i talked about last time but
another friend in new york um his
favorite quote is that people are here
or people come into your life for a
season a reason
or a lifetime and i got
to stop hanging out with those that are
here just for the
reason they're the easiest ones to come
across but they're usually the ones that
are
most
most able to stop you from that progress
in life the season ones
hey that means that they're around for a
good
little chunk of time and for a good
solid reason and that's a good thing
but i need to find those lifetime ones
and allow myself that standard
that i do put on myself
and not allow myself to be
coerced so easily so
agreeing to give
what california has taught me is that
yeah like i said just before we started
recording
it seems like the california state model
or la's or something is that
what's in it for me and i
hate that that where's the good
mis-kindness out of compassion just
out of your heart for doing something
all these topics that you just spoke
spoken about
they all boil down to love yeah it's it
you wipe away all this bs all this crap
and it
it you boil everything down to its
essence it's always about
i need love
but yes this the real unconditional
accepting
love whether it's career we're talking
about whether it's
relationships whether it's about and it
doesn't necessarily mean
physical sexual relationship because you
can have that type of connection
with platonic friends as long as you
know they're
you know no there's many ways to be
loving i'm not saying a physical
romantic relationship
someone that's on your team that has
your back with um unquestionable i have
male friends
i'm straight i have male friends that
i know beyond a shadow of a doubt love
me and i love them
exactly and they would do anything for
me yeah and i would do anything for them
exactly and that's hard to find
that is hard to find and
when you have lived
from the life i have um it's almost like
i'm
making that opportunities harder to find
because those that
engage in the similar practices i do you
know
they're just there for the reason not
the season not lifetime
and i don't like that that's a horrible
way to go with your life thinking these
are your friends
oh yeah because they're far from it
exactly
but they kind of look like it so you let
them in you have to be
and and that's what they again learn not
to be so gullible
it's important to know the difference
between a somebody who looks like a
friend and oh yeah something to do next
weekend or
somebody who's truly a friend and very
often a lot of people don't know the
difference
acts like missouri show me
show me that you are you know
that person that you claim to be in
order for me to i don't take that
combative attitude about it you just you
either recognize it or you don't
you don't need to you know i don't i
don't put anybody through a proving
process exactly i hate
it i had someone even basically spell
that out to me that's how they operate
and i'm thinking myself
hey hey hey out of that though
by just simply saying
i need to see a worth not necessarily
you know x the number of like oh you're
taking care of me five times that means
you're a pale
no no it's not like that it's just
a lot of it boils down to how you see
them interact with others
yeah because that's their true self
whatever they show to you is whatever
but
analyze how they work with others
and that's what that is is by showing me
it's like do i see that same type of
compassion concern respect for all
peoples
um i've had some that you know you
thought we're all cool and everything
and then
they say the things that make you pack
your head and turn like what the f
is wrong with you and so
i have to be very mindful of myself and
remain guarded like a poker player i
mean i don't have to show my cards
immediately
but you know once i'm comfortable
and there is uh the thing don't get too
comfortable too early
with anybody
and that's where that when i was saying
like kill me whatever like missouri
no i don't want to be missouri but i
want to be
but it's important to go through your
life without too much fear of who's
who's screwing me over
yeah and also not to be too gullible
love the universe a lot of physics that
that balance is and there's part of the
flaws that i can see in myself is that i
am
too gullible too trusting that's why i
am
yeah i would detect a few blocks from
skid row before i live i would tend to
be
put myself in that same category i'm
much more trusting than i
could but most than most people doing
what you do
i'm sure allows you that opportunity to
grow more than what you were before
because you're seeing everyone's story
everyone's singing that's what
motivates you well i've always been
super curious yeah exactly so
that's that's been since birth so so
that leads me down to this kind of
project
right and that's really awesome um
i don't know your star sign or whatever
your gastrological sign but i mean i'm
on pisces i don't buy this
astrology stuff though of course oh no i
mean it's not like you know the
horoscope like where you like look at it
in the newspaper like today you're gonna
win five thousand dollars but lose 499
of it so
no no but i feel that there is some sort
of
weight but
a planet's gravitational pull i mean
like look at mars and the moon
has enough gravitational pull to do the
tides
it's not out of the realm of possibility
to me that having
neptune or you know jupiter come into
things that are closer to us even though
they're
hundreds of millions of miles away
i can accept that there might be some
sort of
pull that happens
because
i can feel the pisces people that i know
do sharing traits in myself that are
more pronounced than
other people whereas like some don't
have that compassionate
willing to help out others
genuine honest
and
i forgot where i was going sorry that's
okay that's the benefit of talking too
much
no it's a great talk this is wonderful
oh thank you
we'll cut it off here thank you so much
you're interesting
thank you much i love talking with you
thank you all right
ciao